[Music]
in not worth it news not worth it at all
it's like two exercises you should work
out my mom I know right I'm becoming an
Asian grandma dude everywhere I go my
fiance does this like anywhere at the
gas station submitted by hemoglobin that
is what is coming out of speak when you
come into it really it's not the red
stuff was not blood yeah it's a team
foul to death at a party trying to
retrieve her friend's cell phone she's
like trying to get this off on IP what
happened so it's 15 year old girl she
had she try to save her I felt like it
was a human being
saving her so you were friends I'm like
oh yeah I need friends like that I need
some loyal [ __ ] friends I'll die for
my phone not me girl I know I wouldn't
do for years I don't even give a [ __ ]
about my own phone show everybody your
[ __ ] phone
what do you mean it will seem looks like
it's gone through it works perfect this
is disgusting oh my goodness this is
like the whole thing is credits grown
but when I'm at the gym like what don't
don't throw no I'm at the gym like after
I'm done here it's like that oh my god
that's how I know iPhones are the
[ __ ] best cuz I throw my phone all
the [ __ ] time and it works really good
mmm no thank you
yeah so this girl she
so her parents left she was home alone
her an older cousin was supposed to be
watching over her but then they ended up
going out I told she 15 and then so she
had friends come over so they she had
like sort of like a party at her place
and she's popular
yeah in a nuts when I have like a
commentary cuz I'm trying to think when
I was fifteen I don't have that many
friends to have a party soon right what
I can have like a 30 person party in
like five minutes
one person and they're cool so they
invite everyone but you don't really
know anyone like that was me you know
fifteen if someone was like yo we're
home alone everyone is bombarding the
[ __ ] out of that place
yep I get to myself yeah yeah you guys
are losers you married a loser
hold on you telling me you to have a
fast France to have a birthday party
with my friends not early but not to
fill up a house no Leo that like a party
like it's just small little things but I
don't have like like I'm not silly no I
did but like oh I was like board games
[ __ ] the board gave us do drugs what the
[ __ ] no whenever you party drink and be
sad together that's all but you know so
many people I know I still keep to
myself
no no no invites my house like I don't
really care much any other people only
like a few people I've never been
invited okay
continue please we're not real for
instance yeah so so we're not okay so
she had a party and then one of her
friends left her their cell phone in a
room and that room ended up being locked
somehow and so she ended up going out
through the fire escape trying to get
into that locked room but then she fell
five stories five stories I wish it was
in an apartment this was in Manhattan
apartment oh yeah
so she tried a spider-man her way into
that
through the window uni was a Mochan
Imogen Oh Jay was he Mongolian here
imagine poor girl
yep all right they made good music was
just cute well she's kidding
she looks like baby Jessica Alba but
when this story first surfaced everyone
like there were stories saying that she
was doing it to impress her friends that
she was just trying to show oh wow and
then she was trying to get her phone
like there was just a lot of different
things being reported but now the last
one that I read was she was trying to
get her friend's phone it sounds like
her family's helped her healthy wealthy
to have a multi-story apartment in
Manhattan well I don't know if she owned
multi-story Vegas late than that like
she just lived on the fifth I bet you
her parents dip is all connected
yeah but what was she doing on the upper
floor then or a lower floor you know I
mean what was said that she had to go
through
oh where he's thinking oh right now I
gotta go I bet you her parents are
regretting that they didn't take she
didn't take rock-climbing classes
morning I guess your dress like their
PSA to everyone like put your kids in I
imagine if she was like mom I want to I
want to go bouldering he's like no go
[ __ ] study it's so useless right and
then now you just think back and you're
like if only she had that grip you know
who got that though we already said Tyga
got that so now we just gotta get a
plywood yep and then we got all the
little you got the grip hunky oh you do
get the grips like for real or you ask
somebody gifted em too because you know
when you Boulder and [ __ ] there's people
that [ __ ] being on one toe and [ __ ]
yeah that shit's nuts man looking like a
[ __ ] mountain billy goat you sure
yeah yeah they're actually upside down
again I wonder how she thought what
happened she said let's do it she lost
her balance while she was trying to get
onto the bowl during classes like if she
was just trying not to get in trouble
they weren't drinking as well I can see
that her trying to impress friends like
I don't want to like drag our name and
the dirt but I could see it like that's
his team I made a stupid [ __ ] now that's
true you know to me like not me like I
would yeah you climbed up the white
behind [ __ ] and I do stupid stuff all
day but at least I know if I die it's my
fault but I also think I never die I
don't know like if I would like if I
could decide whether to die because it's
my fault or because it wasn't my fault
I'd rather picked up it wasn't my fault
really yeah cuz then I'd be even more
angry at the fact that I could have
prevented my own death like when your
father like and then people are like oh
that's your fault you and skydiving well
then I guess at that point it's like
well it's your fault for leaving the
house like that's just done like I
wouldn't take it that far
it's like those people that do free
running on [ __ ] skyscrapers dude yeah
you died Chinese guy oh I think if we
did a JK news on him yeah yeah yeah I
remember that yeah yeah I'm so scared of
heights I can't even do like ziplining
mmm I was on his avoiding course paid
like $100 and they had a like emergency
land meters you're too scared I was
crying and suppose you get stuck in the
middle cuz you know like lighter people
they get stuck
we do emergency landing bring a team and
they have like these giant ladders but
they have to like didn't someone didn't
crawl and then get you and then pull you
back yeah that's what they usually do
middle of a zipline so it's like multi
zip lines like it was like a like a 25
could you didn't want to finish it no
it's like no I will die but it's so
funny because like I went with David and
stuff like that right and insane
actually what yeah he was dying yeah so
when we're in Hawaii
so when we went on the trip the last
trip together he's so skinny and he's so
scared of heights
I love his screaming yeah but the
heavier you are the faster you go
so me and David I'm trying to race his
ass right so the one two three anything
you just like he doesn't even kick off
he's just like he goes down like that
yeah I'm like here and I have my feet
and I just push myself as hard as I
could you competitive that and I'm like
trying to go down right and I'm shootin
swinging and swinging and he's [ __ ]
hauling ass are you just going and you
see this guy like Shh the same time yeah
I can't a ball on the feather yeah and
if your life like the long ones you get
stuck in the middle so they don't just
get stuck jeez dad I'm somebody actually
great to do that I know I can't believe
that that's crazy how does it work when
you have balls on zip-lining yeah
because it's like it's it goes like this
yeah I tell you meddling
anyone getting on you mean like getting
the the pull you up and then your balls
are like pulled out cuz your pants about
really like just around like it's almost
like crotchless undies like it just goes
around it right just restroom but it
kind of like brings everything
how many crushable
like I don't I'm trying to picture your
whatever your something like what I
don't know I've seen them but I've never
worn them to give that example it's just
one of those things where it's like
what's the purpose of lingerie nobody
cares you know those like the bras but
then the titties come out with no boobs
we're not the worst oh the worse I like
it and even envision it it's like what
are the ropes doing they're not it I
they don't even stay in place it's like
like the guy wearing yeah it's like a
g-string to once in my life you won't
know it yeah these are fixed so that I
know what you're talking about
no I'm just like that's a pretty good
invention I think crotchless there's no
perfect so every animal once every guys
ever worn those I'm never gonna get you
a yeah right I already could put yogurt
on it as a matter of fact
[Music]
like what is it made of every time I
think of edible I think of fruit roll-up
no cheap candy right oh really man but
I've never worn them oh we have so here
the project article adorable the sweet
points right it's all the beaded ones
that's gonna take so long I think just
to put it on I already snap I also don't
have a buddy so would it no it's so good
when those necklaces were popping in a
candy necklace and the bracelet it would
melt in the hot and with Ritz you're
sweating there's like candy Marshall you
wore it yeah back then an elementary
school I read at the candy watch the
remember the candy candy on my neck like
Smarties a little yeah you're way
smarter at least ring pops did you do
rink I never wore it I just put it here
and then I'd eat it this week cuz then I
know that it's gonna get sticky I hate
feeling sticky maybe that's what I was
I like ring pops to my Grandpop's put
their ball
[Music]